I've had plenty of conversations with
people I've been on Plenty of podcasts
where the opposite person doesn't agree
with only fans and we've spoke very
maturely like adults respectfully and I
agree with a lot of points that someone
who doesn't agree with only fans I agree
with a lot of things they say but it's
the way someone addresses it and I'm
sorry but both of you have been rude and
and the way you address it is really I
know that's the whole point of the
podcast but I could have a conversation
for hours about with somebody who
doesn't agree with only fans and it will
not get heated and I will agree with
things that they say and they'll agree
with what did we what did we say that
was so rude it's the way you speak no no
I'm asking what what specifically did we
say I've already said no you know you
really want to go back over it no please
because I still don't know you said that
you said my time you've got a
four-year-old then you do anything yeah
wow that was a question that's not
really